So here is a private key crypto system in action. Two entities, A
and B, have exchanged keys. A will use the key KA to
send a message to B, and B can decrypt the message
using the same key KA. And similarly, when
B wants to send a message to A it encrypts it let's say using
another private key key B and when the message comes over here A will decrypt
the message using the same key that was used for encryption namely key B. So one
of the things that should be obvious is
that, in order for this private key encryption
system to work, both the entities need to
know when they get an encrypted message who
is the author of the message, because that is the only way they know what key to
use in order to decrypt this message. So
if a sends a message to b,it's sending this
encrypted message. When this cyphertext arrives here, for
B to know that it has to use this
key KA, it needs to know the identity of
the sender. So the identity of the sender has
to be sent in cleartext. So this is the format of a message that is going from A
to B. The identity of the sender in cleartext Meaning that, looking at
this, we will immediately know, this message is from sender A, and
therefore, I should use key k A to decrypt the cyphertext, and
vice versa when A gets a message from B. Of course, k A and
k B can be the same, or in other words, it is the same key that is used
for, A to send a message to B as well as for B to send a message to
A. But the important thing to take away is
that the key that is used for encryption and
decryption of a given message is exactly the same,
that's the idea behind the private key encryption system.